en face à la radio alors françoise vous
pensez à quoi en ce moment là je pense
avoue thierry c'est quoi vraiment
pourquoi vous fait la grimace avec votre
bouche là et c'est grâce à ça oui j'ai
remarqué qu'il a des dents
particulièrement est un centre alors
vous pensez vous pensez pas des
conneries comme ça on pensait le voir
couper ça remonte à tellement le plus
criant démission il a groupé vous pensez
à quoi la met à vous et à votre sourire
colgate et va garder par contre garder
au montage quand vous regardez le matin
dans un miroir vous lui dites quoi non
mais j'ai un miroir vraiment j'ai
déménagé et pas très longtemps et le
miroir on voit rien donc ça va et en
plus quand j'ai pas mes lunettes je vois
encore moins bien les choses
donc je ne me dit rien parce que ça va
envoyer c'est à peine attention vous
auriez met à ressembler à quelqu'un vous
étiez petit ressembler à qui quand
j'étais petit mais figurez vous que je
collectionnais des photos d'actrice est
la première actrice que j'ai trouvé
d'une beauté sublime c'était marina
vlady elle était belle et je crois
qu'elle est toujours l rsquo vais très
très bien ah oui et puis à une bardot
bien sûr et ma mère qui m'avait acheté
une
une robe en vichy rose qui ne m'allait
pas du tout c'est une catastrophe comme
je vais essayer vous soyez prête à tout
quitter pour le grand amour non non
parce que le grand amour est derrière
moi je pensais pas qu'on puisse se
mettre deux fois dans sa vie un gène est
plus que deux fois dans ma vie à sa ses
premières et à la non mais c'est à ce
moment le sait en plus jean marie périer
mais ça fait 3 à 6 on va faire jouer je
n'ai jamais pas joué ce soir chez lui
les jus de françoise hardy ah ouais jean
marie perrier jacques dutronc est un
acteur anglais qui s'appelait une ride
au moment où il a été marié voulait pas
divorcer et au moment où france pas du
tout la question c'est que c'est la
question ce n'est pas ça pour lui
j'étais j'étais une aventure quoi est-ce
que vous vous sentez très intéressant
pour moi de porter cette crise est
acteur il est connu non non c'est un
acteur anglais joe sacco du tsoup cités
romero c'est au moment où il est il est
et il était vraiment pas mal du tout
c'était l'époque où jean marie périer
était un peu volage un peu un feeder
jean marie périer l'a jamais été volage
il l'est devenu quand moi je le suis
alors pourquoi vous êtes allés avec
l'anglais alors mais parce que parce
qu'il était à tomber à la roma et ses
lacs du trot enlevé ses lunettes qu'il a
mis des lentilles et qu'il devenait beau
c'est à ce moment là
non non non mais c'est à dire que je
suis resté un peu scotché à cet acteur
anglais qui était très embêté est que
parce que pour lui c'était il n'avait
jamais été question d'avoir une relation
suivie avec moi je crois que la même
année d'ailleurs il a eu dans sa vie moi
il brigitte bardot il a fait plus fort
que bob dylan et qui n'a eu ni l'une ni
l'autre et donc et qui les voulaient
toutes les deux un temps et donc donc
ces secteurs très charmant me voyez
temps en temps avec avec jacky me disais
mais il est cent fois mieux que moi
il est cent fois mieux que moi c'est
avec lui il faut être
il avait raison marie et sa durée quand
même temps mais sanaa ça a été une
aventure très épisodique voix très
épisodique et c'est très agréable
quand avez vous pleuré pour la dernière
fois que je pensais qu'il ya pas
longtemps il ya eu un délit terrible et
gens venaient me course avec mon quasi
bourré mon panier bourg etc
j'ai glissé sur une feuille je suis
trouvé les quatre fers en l'air et l'âge
est là ça a été mon entraîneur fit
sienne dans le troisième âge est
vraiment génial
non vous changeriez quoi en vous si vous
aviez une baguette magique le cerveau
oui oui je prendrai le cerveau je ne
sais pas moi détiennent emile baulieu
tiens que pourriez-vous dire depuis le
négatif sur vous
je chante comme un pied et est même je
chante moins bien qu'un pied non je suis
d'accord je suis aussi si votre lui
était à refaire qu'est-ce que vous ne
referiez pas pareil je serai je serai
moins dociles - et moi moins prévisible
un peu plus insaisissable sur voilà oui
je sais ça marche tout le temps ça nous
surprend
il faut être insaisissable fusil il faut
foncer tellier faut-il payer votre
instinct mal de conquêtes et a fait les
courses et les noms je fais pas fait
gaffe à l'état comorien absents on
apercevoir sa succession en dormant bah
ouais moi c'est pas mal arrive moi ma
belle mère et moi il morte dans son
sommeil
c'est pas drôle évidemment pour la
personne qui se réveille à côté d'elle
quand de belles choses
bah
je trouve très en forme mois dernier est
venu là vous étiez ap qu'est ce qui
c'était parce que la dernière fois il
fallait défendre quelque chose de très
compliqué et se trouvait dans une
émission comme ça où il faut mettre un
océan dans une petite bouteille c'est
très difficile ces traders plus cher
thierry que vous n'aviez pas lu une
seule ligne de mon livre et que vous
m'avez donc posé de très mauvaises
questions auxquelles il était très
difficile de répondre et vraiment je me
suis sentie exactement marabout qui fait
cette analyse éric tessier vous qui
connaissez bien les des planètes
il ya de la vie et de la vie sur jupiter
vous croyez